الى روسيا وتصريح للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الرئيس بوتين قال لنا
بلاده نشرت في بيلاروسيا 10 طائرات قادره
على حمل اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه وبناء منشاه
تخزين نوويه في الاول من يوليو المقبل
وقال بوتين ان سبب هذه الخطوه هو بيان
بريطانيا بشان امداد اوكرانيا بذخيره
اليورانيوم المنضب واصفا البيان بمحاوله
غربيه لتعطيل مساعي الوساطه الصينيه واشار
الرئيس الروسي لان ذخائر اليورانيوم
المنظم التي سيرسلها الغرب الى كياف لا
تعتبر من اسلحه الدمار الشامل لكنها تخلق
بطريقه ما غبارا مشعا وبالتالي فهي خطيره
جدا ولابد من ان يدرك الجميع ان الذخائر
التي تضم اليورانيوم المنظم ستلوث الاراضي
الزراعيه في اوكرانيا كما قال بوتين
لا غريبه في الامر في الولايات المتحده
تفعل ذلك
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه منذ مده طويله في
اوروبا على اراضي ست دول من حلفائها في
النيتو سنفعل الشيء ذاته من دون انتهاك
التزاماتنا الدوليه في اطار معاهده منع
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لقد ساعدنا
زملائنا في بيلاروسيا وجهزنا 10 طائرات
حربيه بيلاروسيه لاستخدام مثل هذا النوع
من الاسلحه